je crois qu'on peut affirmer que les
épreuves du labyrinthe ont été un franc
succès
il est encore tôt pour le dire mais ils
sont peut-être la clé de tous nos maux
il est temps maintenant de passer à la
phase 2 bienvenue sur la terre brûlait
le monde ne tient qu'à un fil derrière
cette porte vous attend le commencement
d'une nouvelle vie thomas il fait pas
tout seul là bien au teint
que peux tu me dire ce week end je me
souviens qu'ils m'ont envoyé dans le
labyrinthe
je me souviens de mes amis sont morts
devant moi n'as tu pas envie de
comprendre envie de comprendre quoi
comment tout ça est arrivé
mais avant j'ai une question de quel
côté études il nous cache quelque chose
arrêtes tu es sûr de rien qui nous ont
menti ne s'est pas évadé
ça fait partie de leur plan ils nouvelle
quoi maintenant
thomas sortir du labyrinthe c'est une
chose mais survivre sur la terre brûlée
en et îlots
rapide
du cours de votre existence dépendra
l'avenir de l'humanité
vers la lumière ou l'obscurité